my name is Jacob Weaver and I am a
senior here at Hillsdale College and I
am also president of the Hillsdale
College Federalist Society
we are the actually the second
undergraduate chapter ever created for
the Federalist Society and we are very
proud and honored to be on this campus
so that is my shameless plug of the
evening tonight it is my great honor and
privilege to introduce one of the finest
minds of our day judge dear mando
Scanlon a first-generation Irish
American received his JD in 1963 from
Harvard Law twenty-three years later in
1986 he was appointed to the United
States 9th Circuit Court of Appeals by
President Reagan between graduation in
his appointment
Jojo Scanlon served as the Deputy
Attorney General of Oregon the public
utility Commissioner of Oregon and the
director of the Oregon Department of
Environmental Quality he additionally
served 23 years in the US Army Reserve
and National Guard including four years
as an enlisted man he received he
retired from the reserves in 1978 having
attained the rank of Major
as a judge on the 9th Circuit Judge Joe
Scanlon has participated in over 11,000
federal cases and has written hundreds
of published opinions on a broad range
of subjects including constitutional law
international law and administrative law
he hears cases throughout the Ninth
Circuit the largest Circuit Court in the
United States travelling everywhere from
San Francisco to Anchorage to Honolulu
he assumed senior status on December
31st 2016 in 2004 President George W
Bush appointed judge au Scanlon to the
Board of Trustees of the James Madison
Memorial fellowship foundation and Pope
Benedict the sixteenth coffered the
order of st. Gregory the Great
judge and mrs. Scanlon in 2007 Chief
Justice Roberts appointed judge Oh
Scanlon to the international judicial
Relations Committee of the US Judicial
Conference and subsequently appointed
him chairman in 2009 and the Society of
Kings ins in double into Ireland elected
judge Oh Scanlon as an honorary bencher
in 2016 please join me in welcoming
judge dear Mendez Scanlon
[Applause]
Thank You Jacob for such a lovely
introduction I appreciate it very very
much I'm particularly grateful to my old
friend dr. Larry Arne for his gracious
invitation to speak here at Hillsdale
College I'm a neither reader of dr. arns
and was impressed by the connection he
drew between religious liberty and
property rights in one of last year's
issues of in Primus I commend that piece
to you if you have not already read it
now I understand that Hillsdale
continues to emphasize ancient and
Western literature along with American
history and the Constitution and in its
curriculum an emphasis I wholly
appreciate having previously hired three
law clerks with Hillsdale degrees two of
them are co-teaching teaching with me
this week and with Gil West's older
brother on the way for the 2018-19
judicial year I have come to learn that
a Hillsdale Graduate is exceptionally
well educated well-read and well minded
and I would like to ask all three of my
former law clerks who are a Hillsdale
graduates pleased to stand and I'll
introduce them to you
from inside out is first of all Ryan
Walsh
I don't recall your specific graduation
year Meghan lacy and James Joseph all
three have served as my former law
clerks and as I mentioned Gil's brother
is coming very soon in about another
year I'm delighted to speak today on a
topic
that is of great importance in the
American constitutional system the
increasing politicization of the
judicial branch and if you will excuse
me for just a moment I find that another
set of glasses makes it easier for me to
read these remarks allow me if you will
to return to a time just over 30 years
ago it is 1986 and I've just been
nominated by President Ronald Reagan to
the United States Court of Appeals for
the Ninth Circuit only one month later I
have my Senate confirmation hearing
lasting about 20 minutes and
characterized by none of the theatrics
that so routinely occur today I returned
to Oregon with no fanfare no press
criticism nor false innuendo swirling
around me a week later I am unanimously
confirmed by voice vote and the entire
process takes six weeks well it's hard
to reconcile that account of the
judicial nomination process with the
Kabuki theater that describes judicial
confirmations today millions of dollars
are spent by interest groups either to
halt a nomination or to push one through
judicial decisions are casually labelled
as politically conservative or
politically progressive without any
pause judges are routinely seen as
politicians just take a look at the
commentary and the headlines after the
Citizens United case was handed down the
Washington Post which disapproved of the
decision
describe the ruling is a victory for
Republicans stating the far-reaching
ruling marks a triumph for Senate
Minority Leader Mitch McConnell the US
Chamber of Commerce and numerous other
business and conservative groups after
Bush versus Gore Jeffrey Toobin
referencing the five justices in the
majority road
the least we can expect from these men
and women is that at the politically
charged moments they apply the same
principles that guide them in everyday
cases this ultimately is the tragedy of
Bush vs. gore just last month cNN has
excoriated Chief Justice Roberts for not
making a political statement concerning
president Trump's pardon of Maricopa
County Arizona Sheriff Joe Arpaio the
headline blared top judges remain silent
as Trump pardons Ohio and then there's
Linda greenhouse the influential legal
reporter for The New York Times who
branded newly confirmed Justice Gorsuch
with her version of The Scarlet Letter
Trump's life tenured judicial Avatar and
recently during Professor Amy Barrett's
confirmation hearing some senators
dusted off sorted anti-catholic
insinuations that were reminiscent of
those that dogged John F Kennedy in his
1980 presidential campaign the dogma
lives loudly within you explained
senator Feinstein and Senator Durbin
questioned whether Barrett considers
herself an Orthodox Catholic
no mention of professor Barrett's
sterling credentials nor the plethora of
bipartisan support from lawyers and
academics the increasing politicization
of the judicial branch is a cancer that
strikes at the very heart of American
ideal of self-governance and I hope to
outline this evening how we came to this
point and how we might start the process
of remission
justice scalia liked to say that in our
constitutional scheme structure is
destiny he was fought on our governing
structure is promised on the principle
that government must be split into
co-equal coordinate branches that check
each other this separation of powers
relies on a judiciary that vigorously
enforces the constitutional text against
encroachments by overzealous legislators
as well as executive branch officials
but the judiciary was never designed to
displace these other branches as
Alexander Hamilton opined in Federalist
number 78 the general liberty of the
people can never be endangered so long
as the judiciary remains truly distinct
from both the legislature and the
executive this concept of the judiciary
is reflected in the Constitution itself
we federal judges are given lifetime
appointments in order to foster
independence and to encourage neutral
judgment I fear however
that our branch is becoming politicized
in a way that strays far from the
original design and no single entity is
to blame rather many facets of the law
as an institution from courts and judges
to activist litigants to law schools
themselves have contributed to this
state of affairs let's start with us
judges unfortunately we are not immune
from blame when it comes to the problem
of politicization of the judicial branch
discovery of new so-called fundamental
rights by judges was never contemplated
in the Constitution as Justice Clarence
Thomas has noted the Fourteenth
Amendments Due Process Clause is not a
secret repository of substantive
guarantees against unfairness and yet
not coincidentally as the courts find or
shall we say invent more and more
fundamental rights political strife in
developing courts only increases here
are some of the most memorable in 1965
and Griswold versus Connecticut the
Supreme Court held that specific
guarantees and the Bill of Rights have
ten numbers and one of these penumbra's
is a right to privacy in 1973 the
Supreme Court gave us Roe versus Wade
which found a fundamental right to
abortion thirty years later the court
ruled in Lawrence vs Texas that a state
law banning sodomy violated
constitutional right to private sexual
conduct and just two years ago in
obergefell versus hodges a five
justice majority of the court held that
the United States Constitution includes
a fundamental right to same-sex marriage
declaring such rights by judicial Fiat
rather than through a robust political
debate in Congress and state
legislatures has been made easier
through the use by judges of imprecise
interpretive methods and an unchecked
temptation to play the role of
legislature once untethered from history
and tradition constitutional text can be
hijacked and deployed as an empty vessel
carrying whatever avant-garde legal
theory or newly found right the judge
deems worthy you know Berger fell the
court had the temerity to acknowledge
that the Constitution contemplates that
democracy is the appropriate process for
change but then turned around and
overruled the laws of many states and in
Planned Parenthood versus Casey which
reaffirmed Roe versus Wade we were
assured that it is conventional
constitutional doctrine that where
regional people disagree the government
can adopt one position or the other
alas actions speak louder than words
when in numbers and the mystery of human
life are used to define fundamental
rights or protected liberty interests
the right of the people to govern
themselves is irretrievably lost and
this happens because judges are no
longer constrained to the text of the
Constitution in defining such rights it
is a natural consequence of these
actions that people would begin to view
the judiciary the trustee and arbiter of
constitutional rights as merely a
political organ as a judge on the ninth
circuit I guess I've had a front-row
seat in compassion in dying versus state
of Washington our court City and Bank
invalidated laws adopted by eight states
that prohibited assisted suicide I
descended from the courts refusal to
rehear the case by a full and Bank Court
writing and I'll quote this passage from
the opinion there is absolutely no
historical tradition of protecting
assisted suicide almost all states
forbid assisted suicide and some states
even permit the use of non deadly force
to thwart suicide attempts these are the
political judgments made by the
democratic process if they are no longer
politically correct let the legislators
act to change them not life tenure
judges immune from the voters reach end
quote although my concerns were
vindicated when our court's decision was
unanimously reversed by the Supreme
Court there remained deeper
philosophical damage that reversal
couldn't really mitigate
this trend continued at times
prominently as in the 2014 case of Latta
versus otter in Latta
a panel of our court found that the laws
of Idaho and Nevada which defined
marriage as between a man and a woman
were unconstitutional it is crucial to
recall that Latta was issued prior to
the Supreme Court's ruling in obergefell
importantly long before Latta was
decided the Supreme Court had dismissed
a same-sex marriage appeal in Baker
versus Nelson quote for want of a
substantial federal question unquote
until obergefell was decided Baker
should have guided our decision
nonetheless that panel reached out and
grabbed for itself the authority to
overrule the majority of citizens in two
states in that case and as I wrote at
the time and again I'll quote from the
opinion dissenting opinion the panel's
opinion cuts short these earnest and
profound debates silencing the voices of
millions of engaged and politically
active citizens such a view as shoes the
very foundational premises of democratic
self-governance and quote by a known by
ignoring Baker our court waited
needlessly into a full throttled
political debate hobbling our claim as a
neutral independent arbiter and so the
perception persists that judges are mere
extensions of political activity
reaching decisions through political and
not legal choices
might I say with respect and regret we
judges have invited this perception by
employing legal reasoning divorced from
text history and structure our courts
have resolved vexing social issues in
place of legislators and consequently
thrust our branch into the crosshairs of
politics as Justice Scalia said about
the confirmation process if judges are
routinely providing the Society's
definitive answers to moral questions on
which there is ample room for debate
then judges will be made politically
accountable yet judges and courts are
not solely to blame given the increasing
propensity of courts to resolve such
hot-button questions activists litigants
have begun to treat the courts like
roving legislators and not like legal
tribunals in a recent profile of the
American Civil Liberties Union in
Rolling Stone magazine the author stated
that Americans are looking to the
judicial branch to prevent American
democracy from jumping the rails in
discussing that organization and its
role in our society today the magazine
exclaimed the American Civil Liberties
Union is eager to leverage the courts
and the Constitution to block the most
dangerous parts of Trump's agenda
no one disputes that the judicial branch
has a duty indeed it is our role fairly
to enforce the Constitution including
the Bill of Rights as written but in our
system of government recourse on matters
of policy choices should be directed to
Congress and the legislators and not to
courts these days Congress seems only
too eager to avoid having to decide
crucial issues but courts have no
warrant to engage in the
rough-and-tumble world of politics in
fact this view of courts has become so
commonplace as to be expected in a
Politico West website piece discussing
energy policy the author approvingly
noted you'll definitely find lawyers
from the Sierra Club the boots on the
ground in the war on coal as activists
litigants come to be viewed as boots on
the ground in policy disputes we can
expect that courts will continue to
become politicized as we become the
epicenter of political skirmishes but I
am afraid this view of the judiciary is
ingrained and reinforced long before
lawyers reach the courtroom to my
increasing dismay law schools have
undergone a sweeping shift in how they
present and teach the law to students
when I attended law school at Harvard in
the early 1960s the so-called legal
process school was dominant then we were
taught that judging is limited to the
reasoned elaboration of
in symbols and policies that are
ultimately traceable to more
democratically legitimate decision
makers in other words we were to operate
from the common premise that judges are
to apply neutral principles in an
even-handed manner to all cases before
them today a number of professors at law
schools emphasize to their students that
judges are not neutral actors but merely
politicians donned with black robes
critical legal theory which today
encompasses many subgenres such as
critical race theory or feminist legal
theory is fundamentally convinced that
law and politics cannot be separated
this blending of law and politics in an
academic setting instills in students
who are just beginning their legal
careers that lawyers and judges are not
operating based on texts or precedent
but purely on political bias and
machinations as a new generation of
lawyers takes shape we should not expect
students versed in these theories to D
politicize the judiciary in fact one
would expect quite the opposite take
mark to sh'not a new now assuming now a
professor at Harvard Law School toch net
rights conservative decisions on class
action arbitration should be understood
as part of a long-term project of
defunding the left much of the current
courts voting rights jurisprudence
strengthens Republican efforts
selectively
to shrink the electorate
I doubt that you would hear such an
academic insight promoted on this campus
the insinuation is damning even if
professor Tuschman acknowledges that
these doctrines are not consciously
designed by judges to achieve these
effects in the same piece touch net
anticipating a Hillary Clinton
presidency encouraged appellate judges
to flout the law in favor of progressive
political goals saying right now more
than half of the judges sitting on the
courts of appeals were appointed by
Democratic presidents those judges no
longer have to be worried about reversal
by the Supreme Court if they take
aggressively liberal positions Richard
Posner an influential and oft cited
former judge on the Seventh Circuit and
a senior lecturer at the University of
Chicago Law School once compared
constitutional decisions by the Supreme
Court to choosing between a margarita or
a cosmopolitan it is rarely possible to
say with a straight face of a Supreme
Court constitutional decision he wrote
that it was decided correctly or
incorrectly indeed Judge Posner has
suggested that in his words judges have
to be political animals such Cavalier
analysis affords students and others for
that matter the opportunity to blame
decisions they do not like on politics
it devolves legal analysis into cable
news pundit Rhee and pressures the next
generation of attorneys and judges
to approach legal issues with the eye of
a politician and not of a lawyer some of
you may react to the increasing
politicization of the joushi area by
asking so what why should I care to
share the answer to that question is to
recall the singular building block upon
which the judiciary rests legitimacy as
judicial as Justice Scalia reminded us
in his obergefell dissent and I'll quote
with each decision of ours that takes
from the people a question properly left
to them with each decision that is
unabashedly based not on law but on the
reasoned judgement of a bare majority of
this court we move one step closer to
being reminded of their impotence
unquote Justice Scalia was right to
sound the alarm the American public's
faith in institutions is at an all-time
low only twelve American 12 percent of
Americans have a great deal or quite a
lot of confidence in Congress just 21
percent of Americans have this level of
confidence in big business and only 27
percent in newspapers at the current
moment 40 percent of Americans have
confidence in the Supreme Court
nonetheless it would be folly to believe
that the courts are any less immune from
public backlash than Congress or
newspapers or industry if the public
were to lose faith in the courts
believing that courts were not neutral
arbiters but political actors
the judiciary would be at risk of losing
our legitimacy as Hamilton reminds us in
Federalist 78 the executive branch
wields the sword and Congress holds the
purse but reasoned judgment and not the
sword or the purse is what inclines the
other branches and the public to respect
our decisions otherwise we may not be
too far off from a repeat a president
andrew jackson's famed retort to chief
justice justice Marshalls decision in
Worcester versus Georgia John Marshall
has made his decision now let him
enforce it
after all that do I despair no I remain
ever hopeful that the creeping
politicization of the judiciary can be
decelerated if not reversed I have two
thoughts on how we may move forward one
for me and my colleagues and one for all
of us here tonight first judges must be
vigilant in resisting any temptation to
let our personal political beliefs
conservative liberal or otherwise guide
decision making our constitutional role
to decide cases and controversies it's
nothing more and nothing less the
further we move away from our anchors in
interpreting the Constitution texts
precedent structure and history the more
we resemble a legislature and not a
court
humility is paramount in staying within
our constitutional sphere we federal
judges are not elected by the people and
we are cloaked with life tenure once
again I must turn to the ever prescient
Justice Scalia hubris is sometimes
defined as or weaning pride and pride we
know goeth before a fall
one need only look down at our courtroom
attire to be reminded of our role in the
American system of government just as
judges wear black robes because when we
ascend to the bench
we represent the law and not our
personal selves I am heartened by the
appointment of justice at Gorsuch who
stated in this confirmation hearing
these days we sometimes hear judges
cynically described as politicians and
robes seeking to enforce their own
politics rather than striving to apply
the law impartial II but I don't think
that's what a life in the law is about
all right second good citizenship and
here's where you come in we as a society
bear responsibility for our system of
government as Benjamin Franklin departed
the Constitutional Convention he was
asked by an onlooker what type of
government the delegates had agreed on a
republic if you can keep it he replied
good engaged citizenship starts with
education alexis de tocqueville the
great observer of american society and
culture
noted
in the Nations by which the sovereignty
of the people is recognized every
individual possesses an equal share of
power every individual is supposed to be
as well-informed as virtuous and as
strong as any of his fellow citizens
essential to our republic is
appreciating that courts are not the
fora for public policy disputes
legislators are we should not decry the
silence of Courts on political questions
we should celebrate it perhaps you can
begin by demanding that Congress do its
duty by taking up the pressing issues of
our day instead of defaulting to the
judiciary as it so often does try
resisting the urge to seek redress
through activist interest group driven
litigation instead seek to engage your
opponents in order to find resolution
and definitely challenge those who
insist on confusing the role of a judge
with that of a legislature this type of
good citizenship is not just to be
instilled in law schools but in all
schools including colleges at Hillsdale
you have such an opportunity and I see
from my experience how well you are
doing virtuous
tinta mean a gautet strength rejoices in
the challenge as stated so eloquently by
Alexander Hamilton years ago judges have
neither force nor will but merely
judgment
if we stick to judgment not political
policy choices and engender a society
that understands the judiciary's role
our country will be all the better for
it finally I hope that 30 years from now
judicial confirmation hearings perhaps
with a Hillsdale Graduate at the
nominees table will more closely
resemble my confirmation experience 30
years ago then what we see occurring
today thank you very much
I will be very happy to take questions
if there are any yes right in front okay
what is your position on the Fourteenth
Amendment and when the judicial system
can overturn majority decisions
oh my you should be taking the class
that were that my former law clerks and
I are teaching this week okay I find
that to be very very general question
there will be occasions where there is a
state statute which violates the command
and the Fourteenth Amendment which
speaks directly to States that is in
direct conflict with the provisions of
the United States Constitution we do
that on occasion
and hopefully we do it with a rationale
and a an explanation which is complete
and which relates to the direct
provisions of the Constitution and very
often precedence we spent the entire day
to day discussing the extent to which we
have to follow precedents but in in
general that's that's the that that's
the the role that we have to apply other
questions yes
well it's amazing I happen to be on a
very far-flung Court we occupy a million
square miles of territory we include
Alaska Hawaii two territories in the
Central Pacific Guam in the Northern
Mariana Islands to say nothing of
California and my own state of Oregon
and four other states we do get together
for court meetings quarterly the meeting
usually starts with lunch being served
at noon the meeting starts at 12:30
we're usually done by about 2:30 and
everybody rushes to the airport to get
on their flights to go to home to their
different states I don't think we do
enough getting together to really talk
through some of these things now we do
obviously when we hear a case we'll
retire to the conference room on the
robing room where we will sit down and
decide that case more often than not it
seems to me at that stage we don't
invest the kind of time that is really
necessary to accommodate I think what
you're what you're getting at and which
I would like to see more of but keep in
mind that before we hear of the case
there is a lot of work that's already
been done there's a bench memorandum has
been prepared which typically is fairly
thorough and if any one of us feels that
there the bench memorandum does not go
into sufficient depth why our own law
clerks will supplement that so that at
least each of us to the extent anyone of
us feels the need we can have that
additional health but I think it would
be it would be more healthy and even
when we have our annual
retreat it's all on court administration
there's very very little discussion on
on falafels philosophy or the kinds of
things that I was talking about today
yes right here in here my question is
related to the Ninth Circuit itself
there have been several commentators
that have suggested maybe dividing it
due to its size and the great number of
cases it has based on your experience
how do you think that would work in
practice well I'm one of the supporters
of legislation which would restructure
the Ninth Circuit and I came to that
conclusion about five years after I came
on the court which is 25 years ago
there's a little bit of history in 1974
Congress created was called the Hruska
commission that was chaired by senator
Hruska of Nebraska and it concluded that
two circuits should be restructured the
fifth which is at that time was Texas
Louisiana Mississippi Alabama Georgia
and Florida that the fifth should be
restructured and that the ninth should
be restructured they suggested that the
fifth be restructured so that a new
eleventh circuit would be created by
Georgia Alabama and Florida a few years
later the Fifth Circuit went ahead and
did that our circuit judges at that time
I was not on the court to lady six
decided to resist and to maintain the
court in its in in its present alignment
this is a number of bills have been
entered into and for consideration
ever since then in one case one house of
Congress actually passed a split bill
but the issue kept
percolating so that a few years ago in a
commission chaired by justice white the
recommendation was that the Ninth
Circuit be split basically into three
semi-autonomous divisions that would
function as sort of semi-autonomous
circuits nothing happened on that either
this year I have to tell you that
there's a lot of activity going on there
are senators from Idaho from from Alaska
and from Arizona all of whom have
pending bills as well as congressman
from various states and I think there
are about four different alignments that
are suggested the one I personally
prefer is the one that would have a new
rather a new ninth circuit which would
only be three states it would be
California Hawaii and Oregon the
remaining six states would be a new
twelfth circuit it is I testified
actually before the Senate Judiciary
Subcommittee about three weeks ago at a
special hearing in Phoenix Arizona in
support of that proposal and all I can
say is that it seems to have some some
movement some momentum behind it but
unfortunately my arguments for splitting
the circuit are administrative the
circuit is twice as large as the next
largest circuit and four times as large
as the smallest circuit we have 29
judges on the court so that we can never
sit in Bank now sitting in Bank means
you sit with the full court we only sit
with 11
whereas every other circuit including
the second-largest which is the fifth
circuit which has 17 judges they do sit
with all 17 we have never sat with the
the full number of judges in our court
and there are other administrative
reasons to support it but in the end
regrettably the the the the
administrative analysis will probably
not prevail what will prevail is
perceptions on the on the right the
perception is our court is much too
liberal on the left the perception is we
don't want to give up the liberal
reputation that we have and that battle
will continue to engage so keep an eye
out for it it is it is active this is
not a dormant issue as it had been for
the last four to six years this this
time round there's there's some action
okay next question
thank you your honor my name is Bryce
osburgh and my question is about the
blue slip process there's been a lot of
talk lately and I'm sure it hits home
close to you with the nomination of Ryan
bounds and Oregon senators withholding
the blue slip process so my question is
do you think there's abuse there and
what can we do how do we respond to that
with the goal of stemming the tide of
politicization in the judicial branch my
students are very very well informed I'm
very impressed when I took senior status
on January 1st of this year that created
a vacancy under our system federal
judges are appointed for life but after
they have served 15 years and have
reached the age of 65 they can elect
senior status which means they can take
a lower lesser caseload and they don't
have to sit on certain types of cases I
reached that stage quite a few years ago
but I kept my active status until the
end of last year president Trump has
nominated a former law clerk of mind
Ryan bounds to fill my position we have
two Democratic senators senators Wyden
and Merkley and there's been a dust-up
which is outside of my realm but a
dust-up between the White House and the
two senators the two senators have said
wait a minute we want to have a
selection committee and will in effect
tell you mr. president
who we'd like you to appoint the process
of setting up the committee took such a
long time according to the White House
that they went ahead and made the
nomination anyway and so now the two
senators have announced that they will
not return the blue slips now the blue
slips it's amazing it's just a piece of
blue paper that the chairman of the
Judiciary Committee sends to the
Senators
the nominees home state the idea is that
the senator has an opportunity to tell
the Chairman that this nominee is either
personally objectionable in which case
he won't return the blue slip or he has
no objection to to the nominees
continuing through the process chairman
Grassley will up till now at least we'll
only set hearings for nominees for whom
their home Senators have returned these
blue non objection slips that's what
that process is all about we are perhaps
getting into a fairly remarkable
parallel to some of the situations I
described in my speech but in terms of
my specific vacancy neither senator has
indicated any objection to a ryan
bounces qualifications he is a graduate
of I think he was a graduate with honors
from Stanford and then was on the Yale
Law Journal at Yale Law School he was in
the Justice Department as a Deputy
Assistant Attorney General under
President Bush he had been in a private
law firm but more importantly than
anything else he was a former law clerk
of mine so but the Senators have no
objection to any of that the objection
is that they don't they think the White
House should have waited longer until
they have set up a commission which
would then entertain applications from
others indeed in this specific case of
this vacancy the senators did say that
we would like you to appoint a sitting
District Judge who until that
happen had expressed no interest in
being considered the white house was
under no obligation to entertain that
Nam and that that suggestion but it went
ahead and did anyway it invited judge
Hernandez to come back to the white
house where he was interviewed he was
also interviewed at the Department of
Justice the white house which had
interviewed others as well had have came
to the conclusion that they would still
like to stay with Ryan bounds and so
notified the Senators and hearing
nothing further went ahead and nominated
bounds okay
other questions that let's get some
questions from elsewhere Garden dr. Arnn
is a question Oh My heavens I would like
to place it in context so big context so
I think the greatest things that judges
have ever done and the reason some of
them are heroes and the reason the
judges as an institution deserve the
power that they have in the lifetime
tenure that they have is that they have
stood up to executives and legislators
which have armies behind them and if you
want to see if a country is a good
country just look and see if the son of
the Prime Minister or whatever the
tyrant is called will have no better
chance in front of a judge than you have
and there are lots of countries today
where they don't and in some of those
countries I'm necessarily where they the
powerful do have a better chance and in
some of those countries judges do brave
things so your talk was about judges not
being haughty and making laws but we
live in a in a time when we have more
law than we've ever made ever had and
those
laws are made by a very different
process than the Constitution describes
they should be made I looked it up this
leak week for another reason but I
happen to know that last year the
Congress the United States passed 1/2 of
385 law so the two year Congress passed
385 laws but last year in a single year
alone last year of Obama eighty-seven
thousand pages of law were added to the
Federal Register and that's the most in
history and that came from an
administrative system that in my little
opinion is unconstitutional but never
mind that it certainly is not named in
the Constitution so now I wonder if in
that circumstance and given the reasons
judges have the respect they have where
it was born I wonder if you think judges
are in fact not way too shy about about
contesting laws that circumscribe the
rights of individuals well you have to
keep in mind that we can only rule on
cases that are brought before us and not
every case would provide that kind of
opportunity but when they when the the
proper case is brought in others there's
proper standing there is injury asserted
and there is an invocation let's say of
a constitutional right then we will
decide it I don't know I think some of
us are pretty stout in taking on cases
and and deciding them
well in Chevron okay yeah that's that
that's a rather specific question I
thought it was it was broader there is a
as what's called a so called Chevron
doctrine in which the Supreme Court in a
case involving Chevron that's why it's
called the Chevron doctrine allowed the
administrative agency whose regulation
was under consideration to in effect
interpret the statute involved the
challenge was that what the agency did
did not comport with the language of the
statute but the the doctrine that came
down was that this so long as the
statute is ambiguous in other words as
long as you could say that this
federally passed congressional Act has
language which could be and subject to
multiple interpretations then the agency
in charge with the implementation of
that statute has a standing and indeed
must be given deference because of its
experience with the statute it's it's
its role in administering that
particular area of the law some of us
have serious question about whether that
doctrine is valid as a constitutional
matter ironically Justice Scalia had no
trouble with that doctrine for quite a
long time and it wasn't until his is
rather latter days that he began to
suggest that it really needs to be
re-examined now I think just as Gorsuch
has already
gone on record as expressing doubts
about the chevron doctrine but from
where I sit as a judge on an inferior
Court now I hope we're not inferior
because of the people that are on the
court but we are the we are one rank
below the Supreme Court
my role is limited to following Supreme
Court precedent I can't on my own
although those of you in class this week
will give some thought to well maybe I
have just as much right to interpret the
Constitution as the Supreme Court
justice does yeah it's quite likely I
would have to say that sometime in the
next couple of years the Supreme Court
will have a case which will re consider
this the Chevron doctrine and if I have
the opportunity of course I'll have to
follow the Chevron case but I do have
some arrows in my quiver the most
important one I guess is the ability to
write a special concurrence in other
words I can concur in the judgment which
follows Chevron but say that Chevron has
these problems and insight to cases
which have expressed concerns as well as
some of the writers in the field who
have expressed concerns so that that
option is is available to me right over
here
um so in your speech you were talking
about how you didn't appreciate that
we derive rights that aren't explicitly
guaranteed and could you speak louder
I'm sorry I'm hearing you so um you were
just talking about deriving new rights
and how you think that that's you know
not good jurisprudence and I'm so my
question was are you of the train of
thought that the right of privacy was
legitimately derived or do you just
object to how Griswald applied what
brand I said in Olmstead about speech to
something else so what did you not
appreciate about there like deriving
that right of privacy like well the word
privacy isn't in the Constitution
whatsoever and regardless of how you
might feel on the merits of whether that
particular Connecticut statute was
whether you liked it or not the point is
that there is no such protected right as
such in the Constitution now this is one
of those areas where it's going to be
very very very hard to overcome that
precedent that has now come down because
it's it's gotten so widely noted there
there could very well be a case coming
down which which might cabin the right
in some way but to overcome Griswold I
just don't see it in my lifetime but of
course you know I'm 80 years old so it's
it may it it'll probably take longer
than that
it's a pro thank you you don't
appreciate it so it's just the pin
number idea that is not good my
interpretation okay I think that was
justice because that's kind of hell I'm
sorry that's kind of how their ID was it
was a PIN number of like before yeah
it's their writing justice and I'll
think of his name in a moment but he
just developed that I mean that's poetry
that's not law it's really it's it's
kind of existential interpretation with
with without any of the tools that are
recognized in terms of constitutional
interpretation but you'd be amazed how
widely quoted the numbers which emanate
from the numbers from emanations from
certain rites that language has been
quoted in many many cases without any
real firm foundation and I regret that
but that's what we want something we
live with yes well well as I told you in
the right case and I've done this quite
a number of times and I'm happy to say
that on a number of occasions the
Supreme Court with I've written a
dissent from a failure to review it here
you every here in Bank or if I written a
separate concurrence pointing out the
problem the Supreme Court notices these
things and at least in in a number of
cases has used that as a vehicle to
change a or overrule a case which just
overstepped its bounds thank you thank
you thank you
okay
[Applause]